so uh so i'm going to talk about adding
um you know so it'll be a slow start
because we probably all know how to add
um my my friend steven tweeted this a
while back
um if you're building a system for
calculating aggregates and you don't
know the relevance of things like
abelian groups
stop um what
so he's wrong uh he's wrong
in his sort of typical math snob way but
um
you know i think he has a point and uh
and the way i would put it is that if
you are building systems for calculating
aggregates if you're building
stats and analytic systems you probably
do know the relevance of abelian groups
you just don't realize it yet
but it might actually be useful for you
to
not only implicitly understand it but
also sort of explicitly understand it
so the too long donate of this talk is
is first of all adding is awesome
um and uh and we'll talk about the ways
in which adding is awesome and
and those might or might not be
surprising to you for a lot of you
probably they won't be too surprising
but but it's useful to cover that ground
and then the second thing is that
a lot of things that you probably don't
think of as adding
um are adding in in the ways that adding
are awesome and
and that's awesome and that's useful um
so hopefully that'll be surprising to to
a few more of you
so as sort of a motivating example i'm
going to talk about
um statsd or statsd like systems now
um you know if you don't know these
systems they're sort of observability or
metric
systems and and in your code they look
kind of like this so if you imagine
this is the entirety of stripes code
base here if you imagine
uh that stripes code base is you know we
want to process a payment
and we're going to make this transfer
but before we do that we just want to
record
how many monies are going through uh and
so we make a call like stats.increment
and
and we give it a name and and we give it
an amount
and conceptually what's happening is
we're generating a stream of numbers
right a stream of amounts going through
the system let's say
and that's getting sent out in the case
of statsd it's like over udp but it
doesn't really matter it's getting sent
somewhere
and that somewhere has a magic attifier
box
uh and that's gonna add it up and and at
some point we're gonna get a total out
of that
right so so that's useful um
and uh and we can think about you know
how you might
implement this kind of addifier box
right um
and uh and this is kind of you know
ridiculous ruby code but that just kind
of gets across the idea of what this
thing might be doing right it's gonna
start at zero
and every time you send it a number it's
gonna take its its current result and
it's going to add the number to it
right okay hopefully you can all follow
this
so far so um so this has a bunch of nice
properties in
and one nice property that i think is
worth pointing out just from this code
is that we are only needing to hold on
to one thing
right so we have this whole stream of
numbers and you could imagine an
implementation where we just log every
number
um but if we had a huge number of stats
then that would take up a bunch of
storage and so it's nice
actually that edition has this property
that if what we want is the total
you know if we have this stream of
numbers coming in we can actually just
incrementally keep
adding to to this one value that we have
to hold right so that box
just has to have one number in it so you
know that that is a nice property that
is one of the ways in which edition is
awesome
okay let's talk about some other ways in
which edition is awesome so
if all we're doing is is what i just
described where we take this stream of
numbers
and we every time we get one we add it
to our current result
um then then this is sort of
mathematically what we're doing right
we're first adding let's say the stream
of numbers is like 4 8 16 23 42
right um the the first thing we're doing
is adding 4 and 8
and then 15 comes along and we add 15.
so it's kind of parenthesized like that
right does that make sense
okay now in real life with something
like stats d you don't just want the
grand total normally normally you want
to track like
how many you know what was the total for
this minute or for this hour
something like this and so you don't
just have one box you've in fact got a
whole bunch of boxes right you've got
sort of a separate counter for
1201 than you do for 1202 and so on
right
um and so if we imagine a system like
this
you know we might have the four and the
eight come at one minute and the 16 and
23 and so on we have these boxes
um and these boxes all have that
ridiculous ruby code that i showed you
um but and this is another you know way
in which edition is awesome
if we do having separated it out into
all of these individual minutes
want to know what the grand total is we
don't have to go back to the original
stream of numbers
right we can just add up the subtotals
okay
hopefully you are all still following
this um
so you know mathematically you can think
of that as
we're changing the way the parentheses
are right because when we're doing this
um we are going from you know the
parenthesization i showed you before to
here where first we're adding four and
eight
and then separately we're adding 16 and
23 and then at the end we're adding
these
um and incidentally you might have a
minute where no events happen
right and the way i wrote that code you
would end up with a zero um and adding
that in also doesn't
change anything right we we still come
up with the right answer okay
these are these are good things um so
incidentally you know uh mathematically
that's called associativity
um but uh you know i'm trying not to be
too mathy in this talk so that might be
best so
okay so so let's say you know that that
your business grows and the number you
know the
the transaction volume grows and you now
need not just one
magic stats collecting box but several
magic stats collecting box
and you you partition uh the the event
stream
across many of these right um so another
way in which edition is awesome is that
you can do that too right so if you have
some of your numbers going to one box
and some of your numbers going to
another box
um you can then collect them
uh in one place and well you can add
them up separately on each of those
boxes and then collect them
and uh and you still come up with the
right answer right and so now not only
have we changed the parenthesization
um we've also effectively changed the
order in which we're adding these up
right um and uh and the the
pink arrows there are are the point
there is that that's network traffic
right
so we've gone from sort of feeding the
results of something into something on
on the same machine to feeding the
results of something into into
a different machine um and and one of
the
you know important properties here is
that what we're sending over the network
there is actually very small right
because we can do the total
separately on each machine and then just
send the total over the network so
so that's a useful thing so that's
awesome um
and uh and of course you can put it
together right so you can have each
machine
be keeping separate counters for each
minute or whatever
um and multiple machines and you still
have very very little network traffic
let's say
um to get to the the final machine
that's going to add it all together
right so
so these are ways in which addition is
awesome and and we take advantage of
these properties you know all the time
and we build distributed systems
um so that we can efficiently you know
roll up
aggregates and and we can efficiently
distribute things over
many machines and we're not always going
back to the stream okay cool
um now statsd or or things like it
you're not just doing counts you're not
just doing additions
you know another thing another way your
code might work um you know statsd often
has
uh the clients often have like a time
method right so
i want to know how long this took um and
let's say that one thing that we want to
be tracking in our analytics is like
what's the longest it took
right so we want to do a max oh man now
we have to implement a whole nother
thing a whole separate code path
uh we have to have you know another
piece of ruby code by the way
i've turned the box sideways so that you
can tell that this is a magic maxifier
not a magic out of firebox
um but actually the code
the ridiculous ruby code looks almost
identical
uh it's just that rather than adding to
our result
we're maxing with our result right it's
still a binary operation it's just we're
using max instead of plus
and actually all of these same things
that i just went through apply to max2
right so if you keep the max for a
minute
you know each minute and then you max
all of those together you do get the
total max
um it doesn't matter you know what order
you do it in
you can keep sort of separate sub maxes
on each boxes and get the total max
so you can end up with exactly the same
diagram for max
as you do with add well that's kind of
nice right that means that you know
maybe you can implement some kind of
abstraction in your system
over over multiple of these things and
just implement it once
right um so did someone just shout
something
no okay um by the way do feel free to
heckle i'm i'm pro heckler so
um you know so how do we generalize that
well
well let's sort of think through what
what are the properties here that we've
been taking advantage of right so
one property is that both add and max
both plus and max
take two numbers and produce another
number right
um so that's useful because
we want to just keep one thing in the
box right we don't want to have to keep
the whole list
we want to be able to reduce it down to
just one thing so that's nice
another is that the way that we group it
doesn't seem to matter right we can
group it by minute or we can group the
whole thing or whatever
um so that's associativity um another is
that the ordering doesn't seem to matter
right we can distribute it across all
these different boxes and end up adding
things up in different orders and we
still come up with the right answer so
that's commutativity
another somewhat subtler but still
somewhat important property is that
zeros get ignored right so we can have
one of our boxes can be empty basically
but we don't have to treat it any
differently we can throw it in and we
still get to the right answer well
what other things have these properties
the way that i've stated them and it
turns out almost nothing does
right not exactly like this so for
example if we consider min
right which which seems like it should
be almost identical and by the way i'm
i'm assuming here that we're in positive
integers because we were talking about
timing data so
um so that's why zero works for max
right but for min
if you min something with zero you you
get back zero you don't get back your
thing right so zeros aren't ignored so
so this isn't quite right
um but this is when this is when my math
friend comes in and says oh well
obviously what you've got is a
commutative monoid
right i mean duh um
and uh and it turns out if you look it
up that he's right so
so there is uh in in in the field of
abstract algebra and mathematics
there there is a concept of something
called a commutative monoid
and a commutative monoid looks almost
exactly what like what i just wrote up
so it is a set
sunset s in an operation a binary
operation
and the binary operation needs to take
two members of s
and produce another member of s right so
great take two numbers produce another
number
uh it has to be associative it has to be
commutative and there has to be some
identity element
where if you take say you know a
and perform the operation with the
identity element you still get a back
right so that's sort of our zero um and
uh and it turns out that there are a
very large number of these
right and so the basic premise of this
talk
is that if you think of your analytic
systems of your of your aggregation
systems
in terms of commutative monoids right
you can
implement just one piece of
infrastructure
that is doing all the things i was
talking about with bucketing by time and
and distributing over many machines and
letting you do queries in in any number
of ways
but you only need one abstraction which
is the communion of monoid
and and that probably most of the things
if not all of the things you're going to
want to compute
uh over your stats can be represented
this way and that's that's
really not obvious and and i think um
you know most of the rest of this talk
is sort of talking through
a few examples and showing how most
things can be
um squeezed into that framework right
um so let me start with with this
example um and and i'm starting with
this example because it's quite
different
from sort of plus and max in some ways
um
but but it's still useful um and
and the idea here is um it's it's a top
k
so you know let's say that you have um
instead of just the the amounts people
are paying going through
you have like a transaction id and the
amount of the transaction id
and you want to hang on to the top 10
transactions by
by amount for over whatever period of
time you're looking at
right um and so what you have going in
are these sort of lists of um
you know say alice spent ten dollars bob
spent five dollars or whatever and and
what you want to come out
is just the top in this case we're doing
a top two
right so just the top two um so you can
read through the ruby code i don't know
how how obvious the ruby code is going
to be it's also like not the most
efficient implementation you could do
but if you think about what's going on
right if i have one
say top two list and you have another
top two list
right we can always combine them sort
them
take the top two of that and end up with
the global overall top two list
right and the way in which we get there
doesn't really matter
right um so if i switch the order around
we still come up with the right answer
right if i change the grouping around we
still come up with the right answer
we're always taking in top two lists in
or or you know maybe an empty list which
sort of acts as the identity here
and getting top two lists out right so
so this is in a completely right i mean
if you this is not numbers this is some
very different set
this is a set of lists of pairs of
you know ids and and numbers um
but it still has those same properties
of commutativity of associativity
and so we can still implement it as a
monoid and actually
all of the code if we've done our system
right that worked just for adding things
up
will also work for say computing a top
10
which is pretty cool um my note here is
like this implementation is actually
really bad you should just use a heap
but um that would have taken more code
to write so
let's talk about something else let's
talk about averaging right so that's a
really common thing that you want to do
so averaging seems at first like it
doesn't work right
um because the grouping for example like
matters a lot on averaging if
if what our box is doing is just a
straight average operation
um then then this doesn't work because
we're gonna have let's say that we take
these three numbers and and we now have
that six
if we now average that six with
something else right we're gonna get the
wrong answer basically because that six
isn't weighted appropriately right it we
don't have any way of recording the fact
that that six represents like three
items worth right
um but we can think in
in a different set in a different space
right and and so instead of thinking
before we we do this operation we can
transform these numbers
from just being individual numbers to
being let's say
pairs of number and count right um
and now this is actually just addition
again
right so if we just do vector addition
on these um
then we get something which is the the
total
and the count and we can very easily
from that you know we just divide to get
the average back out
right um and so you know this is
this is a pattern that um that's gonna
come up a lot in the talk of sort of
transforming
into another space uh you have some
monoid in that other space
um and then you can get out the answer
that you want right um
again a sort of real life note here you
probably don't want to do it exactly
this way
um because your your sum is going to get
huge right but there are numerically
stable ways of of computing averages
that um
that don't have that problem and that
are still monoliths right are still
communicative and associative
um another very quick example right you
might want to compute histograms
um and so again as your as your data
comes in
um you can transform it you can bucket
it and transform it into a vector and so
the idea here
is that we have vectors from like one to
ten and so our ten we're going to put a
one count in the ten spot or five we're
going to put a one
count in the five spot and again we're
just doing element-wise addition here
right um and so it's it's all the good
things we want it to be
and then we end up with a histogram that
that we can extract out and
and you know use however it is we want
to be using a histogram
right um hopefully that's all
straightforward
um again heckling questions like if
anyone wants to interrupt me go ahead
um so you know i said that there was
this pattern of kind of trans
oh question yes
uh on the previous slide shin to have
been 18 and
six uh uh
oh i'm sorry
uh no so so the idea here is that
um what we are trying to maintain
is a a vector with two elements um
one of which is the total that we've
seen right
and one of which is the count that we've
seen and then what we want to get out of
that is just the average
right in the end like the answer our
query should just be the the average
should just be
six right
ah yeah so that's a really good point
right so we
we would never send this to another box
right
we would keep sending this along
and we would keep aggregating if we're
like aggregating and re-aggregating and
doing all these roll-ups
we would stay in this space right and so
we'd send 18-3 along to the other box
at some point when we actually want an
answer to like show on a web page or
something only then would we transform
into this
but that's lossy right so so at that
point that's just
like for our consumption that's not for
for the computer to keep right and to
keep doing things with so that's
actually a really important point and
um and and brings me actually pretty
nicely to this slide so
um i've switched to java to sort of make
the types clear
and hopefully that's like reasonable for
people to read but um
the the sort of framework that i end up
thinking about this a lot in
is that you know you you actually have
three types involved
um you have your input type um
you have your output type and often
those are the same so in the case of
average like those are both like a
single number
right and then you have your your your s
your set s that you're actually doing
these these operations on
um and so you need to be able to prepare
your input type to get it into the
into the s space right so you need this
prepare that takes an i and returns an s
you then need to be able to reduce in
your s space
right so you need to be able to take a
left s and a right s and produce another
s
and then at some point you're also
you're going to want to present right
you're going to want to take your your s
result which might be in some kind of
hard to understand form
like 18 comma 3 rather than 6 and you're
going to want to get your kind of human
readable version out of that right
and so you have your present that goes
from s to o um
and the point of this diagram is exactly
what we were just talking about which is
that
um you you might have multiple i mean
you in fact
probably will to make this interesting
have multiple layers of reduction
right so you're going to feed in you're
going to reduce
you're going to take the output of that
and then reduce again you might send it
to another box and then reduce again and
so on
but then eventually at some point you
know you're going to want to look at the
answer and then you're going to run it
through present
right and so that's sort of um you know
both conceptually but also like in
practice if you're like writing an
interface in a system
you know that's that's how i think of it
and and i think that's it's a reasonable
framework for this stuff
um so let's talk about uh another
example right so so another thing
um that you might want to do is uh
is compute the number of unique values
right like the unique visitors to your
site
okay so um so it's easy to think about
this
uh in one way as as as a monoid as as
something that has these properties
because
um all you have to do is transform from
from the individual visitors to your
site into a set
with just that visitor in it and then
you can use set union
right and set union uh is a monoid set
union
commute set union is associative right
um but state union has a problem
right um and and the problem here is
that
it's unbounded in terms of the amount of
space that we're going to take
right so although it satisfies all these
mathematical properties it doesn't
really satisfy the system's properties
that we kind of implicitly want here and
and we sort of have um it i i i don't
know
of all those a better mathematician than
me might know of some sort of
mathematical term for this but but in
computer science terms right
we want to bound the space that any
element in the set is going to take
right um and so although this this kind
of looks
nice for for small examples this is
going to horribly fall over
um for large examples and and so the
question is
you know can we do this um in a way that
has bounded space
right um and and the answer is no but we
can estimate it in a way that has
bounded space and
and that turns out to be almost as good
and and so some of you might have seen
um you know this approach or things like
it before but but i think a lot of you
probably haven't so i'll walk through it
so
um so what happens if um when we're
transforming into this space that we're
gonna reduce
uh instead of using the item or a set of
the item we hash the item we hash the
item let's say to a number between zero
and one
okay um what now what what can we do
with that
um what can we do with that in
particular that's going to let us
get a number out at the end which is the
number of unique values that we had
well so we're hashing it to 0
1 and if we think about the number line
between 0 and 1
let's say that we have two unique values
as in that example right they're going
to sit
there and there on the number line
they're going to sit at some random
point in the number line
and that random point is going to be you
know just uniformly
anywhere on the number line right i mean
if we've got a good hash function then
that's going to be true
and so as we add more and more of these
um for some large n that we've we've now
got ticks on this number line
what's going to be the average distance
between any two
marks on that number line right um
so we've got zero one we're uniformly
distributing
a bunch of numbers across the space
between zero and one
and what i want to know is uh what's the
distance between two of them
right anyone um yeah so one over n
or actually i think it turns out to be
one over n plus one
right um but the thing is it's it's it's
a
it's a pretty simple thing actually
right
um and that's the average distance
between any two of those
which means it's also the expected
distance between zero
and the first one right
um and that's the really interesting
thing because that means that if we just
take the min
of all of the hashes then what we can do
to get the estimate back
out is just one over e minus one we just
reverse that
expectation of one over n and we get an
estimate now that's
probably not going to be that good an
estimate right
there's a lot of randomness involved
here there's a lot of probability for
error here
um but we can do it n times
right and so if instead of just keeping
one
hash and taking the min over that we
keep a large number of hashes a hundred
hashes a thousand hashes
um and uh and we do an element-wise min
over these vectors and then we average
it at the end
then actually we get something out um
that is a very good estimate
right and um there's an algorithm that
that is sort of a
an optimization of this that has a bunch
of sort of compression tricks and a
bunch of tricks to make it more accurate
called hyper log log that you might have
heard of
but basically more or less this is what
hyperlog log is doing
um and exactly this incidentally is
something called
minhash signature which which also has a
bunch of uses so
in real life you'd use hyperlog log if
you wanted to compute unique values
you'd use min
hash gives you a bunch of nice sort of
set similarity estimation
bloom filters are also almost this right
you can think of bloom filters as being
sort of
a vector of zeros and ones where you're
taking doing a vector
uh max operation on them right they're
they're actually very similar
and and compose in this way for set
membership but
these are all basically the same idea
just tweaked for sort of different error
rates and hyperlog log i think
if you keep a 1k counter right if that's
the size of your vector
i think it's about 2 percent error which
is pretty good and you can you can
easily get it down to lower error just
by allocating more
right um and so the thing to remember
about this that's interesting right is
that
this works in all of those architectures
and all of those ways that we were
looking at before in addition right so
you know you're used to thinking or i
think most people are used to thinking
about unique values as being something
that you can't aggregate like that right
if i've got a bunch of daily unique
values and i want monthly unique values
i've got to kind of go back to the
source data
but if what you've got is a bunch of
hyperloglog counters for your daily
uniques
then you can just max all of those
together
or min all of those or whatever it is
that you're doing
and then sort of run it through the
present step and get out your estimate
right so you can get much more efficient
sort of online
querying or or you know batch roll-ups
and so on
um of things like unique values um
so so that's pretty cool um
so i'm gonna i'm gonna go through one
more example kind of like this and
and then hopefully there will be time
for questions so um so what about
frequency right so we were talking about
like unique number of uniques but
what about if we want to know how often
say a particular ip address shows up in
the stream or something like this
right um so again you know we could just
have these you know hash tables or
whatever right these maps from
from the the ip address or the visitor
to account and and we can sum those up
and and that works
um and that works fine um
again if you've got a small number of
unique
keys that you're trying to track the
frequency of right but it has the same
problem that has unbounded space
um and so can we come up with a way a
similar way of having something that
that still is a monoid
that has bounded space um and that we
can use in our analytic systems to track
frequency um well you know we the last
time what worked was hashing and and so
maybe we can use hashing again here
um and and so what if
um as the items go through
we hash them to a bucket um
so we take the hash and and then we uh
you know we run modulus to find some
bucket of some fixed size vector that
we've got
right um and we have to be
bucketing these hashes because you know
we're we're
sort of what we want we want more than
what we had before right we can't just
like take them in over these hashes and
we're just going to get unique values
right but but but maybe we can we can
sort of
project it down into this smaller space
right um
and so you know in this case um
we can hash alice to to you know the the
third bucket there we can hash bob to
the second bucket
um alice gets hashed to the third bucket
again and so we add these up and and now
we could see
um if we wanted to query at the end we
could we could hash alice and see that
there was a two
in that column and so that's right alice
appeared twice or
we could hash bob and see that there was
a one um this
also has an obvious problem right um
and uh and that problem is collisions
right
um so what if charlie osha also hashes
to the third bucket
um so now we have a problem because
we're going to end up with three
and so we when we go to do our query
we're going to hash alice and we're
going to look in that bucket and we're
going to see
alice's three not two that you know
that's like a 50
error that's pretty bad right also if we
hash charlie we're still gonna get three
um
and that's even worse because what we're
expecting to get from charlie is one
um and in fact what we're getting is is
three um and so that's
that's really bad um but we can fix
it actually in sort of a similar way to
the way that we fixed the sort of bad
estimate
um with unique values which is we can
use multiple hashes
um and and the way this works is there's
a data structure called account min
sketch
where instead of those vectors as i
showed you you have a matrix so you have
several vectors and each vector uses a
different hash function
right and so in the first row
uh we're going to hash alice let's say
to the third column and so we've got two
alice's
in the second row alice is going to be
hash somewhere else and the third row
alice is going to be hash somewhere else
right so as these come in
um we get you know we we have
one hash function for each row we get
these you know n positions that where
we're gonna increment and we do that
um charlie comes along and you can see
in the first row charlie collided with
alice and so we've incremented that to
three
but in other rows you know the more rows
you have the less probability that
there is that there's going to be a
collision in all of them right so in
other rows charlie is not going to
collide with alice
um and then again you know maybe bob
comes in and bob collides somewhere else
but not in the first row or whatever
um and so in the end when you want to
know what's the value for alice
you look at all of alice's hash
positions and you take the minimum
right um and that is going to be
it's it's an upper bound right it's
certainly possible that there were
collisions there
um but it's going to be sort of the best
upper bound that we have
um and so if you do this again
it's sort of surprising how good this
ends up being as an estimate and so
i think it's something like again if if
you're willing to sort of have a matrix
that's like
you know a few like 500 by five or
something right you know
fits into into a couple of k um you'll
be within two percent
right so you're gonna your your your
real value is gonna be somewhere between
what you have
what you get and like two percent less
than that right so
um so it's really not that bad um
and again these errors right as you
combine no matter how many of these you
combine no matter how much you keep
aggregating and re-aggregating and
re-aggregating
these errors don't go down right so it's
still two percent
so if you have these estimates daily and
then you want to add them all up monthly
and then you want to add all those
monthly ones up yearly or whatever it is
and then you want to add that across you
know your you've got a segment in some
other way you want to add it up
you know that that error rate that
relative error rate right
um stays the same um one
one problem worth pointing out in this
one is that it doesn't actually maintain
a list of the keys
right so you can't go and ask this like
what's the highest one and get a key
back you have to know what the key is
and put that in and get an answer and so
often this is kept this is paired with
something else that is maintaining
like a list of interesting keys um that
we can then feed into this to to get the
answers out
right a couple more points i want to
make before
questions one is that in that tweet at
the beginning it mentioned
abelian groups and i still haven't said
anything about abelian groups
um and that's that's really because um
this talk is about addition not about
subtraction
uh because that's a whole other talk but
um to kind of give you a very brief
abstract algebra overview
there's there's sort of at least three
kind of you know
increasing you can think of this almost
like an inheritance hierarchy and at the
top you've got semi groups
um which have a set and some associative
binary operation
right molnoids are like semi groups but
they add the identity
right the zero element groups are like
monoids but they also add an inverse
so you have to be able to take any
element and from that element get an
inverse element that when you add you
know sort of add those two together they
cancel each other out
right um which is really to say
subtraction
um and any of these can be commutative
and in practice
at least in this kind of a space they
almost always are commutative it's
actually kind of hard to think of things
that that are associative but not
commutative
um or at least things with bounded space
that are so like string concatenation
uh is a monoid um it is associative it's
not a commutative monoid
anyway groups that are commutative are
abelian groups that's the name for them
um and so in general the kind of things
that we've seen that are related to max
that are generalizations of max
are monoids but are not groups right
they're you can't reverse them you can't
invert the max operation um and so you
end up with things like hyperloglog or
bloom filters and so on being monoids
um and things like sums and averages and
count men sketch being groups
and the importance in an analytics
context of a group is that it lets you
sort of roll things back
right so to go back to that original
stripe example where we have these
payments going through
what if there's a refund right so we
want to be able to have an
inverse um and and if we have that
inverse
you know that refund coming down the
stream any of the sort of
sums or averages or frequency counts and
so on we're going to be able to just
combine that in
and and get the right answer but say if
we're tracking you know unique customers
this way
um we're not going to be able to roll
that back right so that's kind of a
useful distinction to to be able to
understand
and then the other point that i wanted
to make is that um
these things end up sort of composing um
recursively and interesting ways right
and so the example i gave you with
countman sketch of that frequency monoid
um was itself using addition right
so we we you know we were finding the
right slot in that matrix and then once
we found the right slot in that matrix
we were incrementing a counter right but
what if the things in that matrix were
not counters
but were like hyperlog log instances
right and it turns out it would still
work
um and so you know it it's not any not
any money would work there you have to
have some kind of ordering because at
the end when you do the query you have
to take them in
um but you can have basically a count
min sketch of hyperlog logs
and and that works right or a histogram
of hyperlog logs or a histogram of
counting in sketches of hyperlog logs or
whatever
right um and all of this stuff will
still work and you can imagine
you know building up interfaces and
classes for this um that
let you compose these things in really
nice ways and and end up with
with the ability to have a very flexible
and general system
um without having to sort of special
case all of this stuff
right so so that's useful um
and so um the the the only system that
that i know of that's open source that
that does
um a lot of this stuff in this way
thinking about it in these terms
is from twitter it's called algebra it's
in scala
um and so for for those of you who do
use scala that's that's a very
worthwhile thing to look at
um for those of you who don't use scala
i have this sort of semi-toy
um simmer that wraps algebra in more of
a kind of unix text-based kind of
command line
interface and uh you know it's it's
it's mostly a toy though we do use it
some in production at stripe right now
but i would welcome people looking at it
and giving me feedback
the other link the other sort of
reference link that i thought was useful
to put up here is
aggregate knowledge has a great blog
where they do great sort of expositions
of these kinds of algorithms and
simulations of them like that they have
a great hyperlog log javascript
simulation and so on
and so if any of what i've said is
interesting that's that's a wonderful
blog to go check out
and apart from that if there's any
questions i'm happy to take them